hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
leverage your empower direct controlled
pa 800
plus to simplify data compliance
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by psyx for more
information on our sponsor
please visit psyx.com
now i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
today's presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce today's
presenter candy ewanto
senior product manager at psyx for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome handy you may now begin your
presentation
welcome to today's presentations on psyx
and powerdriver version 1.3 in achieving
data integrity compliance in the next
generation biologics analysis
i'm handy onto a senior global product
manager
at the cyx ce and biopharma business
unit
in today's presentation i would like to
share our latest empowered driver
version 1.3 there are several notable
advantages
to the empower 3cds direct p800 plus
instrument control it enhances
and streamlines your essay development
and biologic qc data workflow
as well as analysis with the version 1.3
you no longer need the 32 karat software
to run the p800 plus capillary system
a sample sets and method can be created
within the empower software cds itself
in the previous power driver version
1.2.1
some users often utilize the mpower
and 32 karat software hybrid
configurations
where samples were set were created in
32 karat
while the 32 carat software performs the
p800 plus run
data acquisitions were done using the
empower
3 cds vlas acquisition server
this is often time-consuming and
error-prone
as samples informations will need to be
duplicated in both 32-carats
and the empower software the software
interface simplified the process for
data acquisitions and management
along with data processing reporting and
distributions
the ability to perform the entire sample
set
to data reporting within the empower
software cts
is one key advantage to reducing the
scientists workload
as well as reducing the regulatory risk
a centralized location to manage
multiple applications
electronic signature tracking records
traceability and necessary system
control is highly desirable to ensure
regulatory compliance
it also reduce costs in by maintaining a
single software system
as it improves the efficiency in
maintaining the 10 to 15 years of qc
data retention
a typical p800 plus and power system
configurations
made up of the p800 plus
connected to the lace acquisition server
via the gpib usb connector
this gpib usb manages the traffic
between the p800 plus and the lace
acquisition server
the latest computer is connected to the
empower server
in which multiple empower clients can be
connected
via the internet cables or through
wireless connection
the empower driver will be installed in
the lace computer
along with the cyax usb license dongle
it allows data acquisition from the p800
plus
this driver can also be installed on the
client computers for
data analysis purposes without the need
of the usb license key dongle
a newer version of national instrument
driver version
19 will also be used as part of the
system configuration
to allow flexibility in using either the
older
gpib usb hs and the newer version
of the gpib hs plus
this eliminate the need for users to
upgrade to the newer hs
plus version this address some of the
incompatibility issues associated with
the previous
driver version 1.2.1
chemistry tested method templates will
also be included
in the software dvd they are the cests
capillary isoelectro focusing or cief
and also the glycogen methods these
method templates can be used
as a starting base for our users to
modify
and optimize based on their
biologics of choice as part of the
empowerdriver
1.8 product offering the empower p800
plus operational qualification
and calibration verification will also
be available
this operational qualification will be
conducted by our certified
sciac service technician to ensure that
the instrument is performing
to the claims specifications the driver
interface connection will be verified
and a comprehensive qualification report
will also be provided
what's different about this sci-x and
power driver
version 1.3 here are some of the
highlights for the new features and
updates
on the on our detectors product offering
in this new driver we have expanded the
ce direct control
as well as data acquisition using
empower cds
these include all three detectors
the pda uv and the laser induced
fluorescence
we also have expanded the pda and lift
calibration capabilities
along with the expanded calibrations
the d2 sprectrum display now can be can
be
seen in the control panel we also have
added
the ability to turn off or select either
lift
channels in this latest version of the
driver
in version 1.3 we have made several
improvement and enhancement
in version 1.3 the instrument type have
been changed to
p800 plus previously it was set to
backman paste mdq
you can also select different types of
detector
in the instrument method editor here the
detector types of three different types
let's select pda a confirmation window
will pop up
you click yes
and then the various different options
that you can select from such as filter
here you can scroll down and select the
different types of filter
that you are interested in we also have
a various different channels these are
the filter
let's select the uv detector
click yes
the uv detector setting is similar to
that
of 1.2 there's not much changes
significant changes it's going to be in
the lift
detector configurations
so here we have electro ferrogram
channel one and two
for version 1.3 you can select an
acquisition enabled
for either channel 1 and channel 2.
previously both channels are open
all the time that increases the audit
risk
since secondary channel channel number 2
typically just collecting
blank or no run information
let's move to the time program and we'll
take a look at
the various different tasks
let's select inject pressure
this is one of the example
in some of this field you will see a
drop down such as forward
and reverse for the pressure direction
you can also change the different inlet
tray
here in the voltage injection mode
or task
the normal and reverse injection
is now clearly more obvious we also have
added the polarity sign
this is the plus and the minus if
there's an error
uh for example if you type an a10
it which is out of range then the
a an error message will show up
here we're looking at the detector
window in particular pda we
would like to calibrate the pda detector
right now the instrument is calibrating
the pda detector
the instrument is calibrating the pda
when the pda calibration has been
completed
a message will appear in the status
monitor bar
you can now apply those parameters
also in the status bar message will
appear as
you can also look at the message center
this is part of the traceability
here it mentions the pda wavelength
calibration was successful
the numbers 87
denote to the list of the different
types of messages
that has been pre-stored at the in
between the p800 plus
instrument we'll now take a look at
the leaf detector calibration
there are various different buttons that
you can select
either to enter the calibration
correction factor
right now it is set at the manual mode
for direct control over the instrument
you can change the ccf values
and set and the instrument will
recognize
the set value
let's perform an automatic calibration
we'll set the rfe value to 15 capillary
dimension
diameters to 50
and the total length to 30 centimeters
hit start and there's a confirmation
window
click yes
the instrument is now calibrating
there is a message it says place weight
instrument running calibration method
continue on from here the status is
still in the run
preparation mode
instruments passing
homing syringe pump rinse pressure is
going up
as the instrument is calibrating you you
can also see
the activities in the status bar
here we will be performing a pda
calibrations
to the pda detector
click calibrate
instrument is performed in calibration
when calibration is completed
the instrument will denote pda
wavelength calibration was successful
beside the improvement to the driver we
also have added
some enhancement to the methods and data
acquisitions
user can now clearly see the normal and
reverse injection
in the status panel this allows users
to run both the high resolution as well
as the high speed cests
applications method conversion tools
is also available for customers who have
developed numerous methods in the
previous
version 1.2 in the previous version
1.2 instrument type were set at backman
pace mdq
instrument type in version 1.3 is set
at psi xp 800 plus
so there's a need for methods to be
converted
or transferred from the older instrument
type
to the newer instrument type this method
conversion tools is made available as a
convenience for those customers who wish
to migrate the method from the previous
version of the empower driver
keep in mind that you will need to
revalidate those methods to ensure
that we have added additional fields in
version 1.3
we also have added chemistry tested ce
method templates
and i'll be going over some what
some of those method templates include
in the data processing we have also now
added custom calculations
this custom calculation enabled
calculations
of the velocity calculated area
currently empower software only offers
time corrected area we also have
custom calculations for molecular weight
estimate as well as standard curve
the pi value estimate in the cief
along with the standard curve
[Music]
the instrument error messages has been
expanded to be more descriptive
this allow simplifications for
troubleshooting
as well as error log traceability
in addition we are offering sax
operational qualifications
and calibration verifications as part
of the empower driver version 1.3
in this software demonstration i'll be
showing you
the various different types of method
templates that's currently offered
data analysis creating a report
and calibration curve to perform more
like a weight
estimate there are three different sets
of method templates
each of these sets containing the
conditioning
separation as well as the shutdown
procedure
we have a cief fast
glycan methods and
igg high resolutions as well as igg
high speed methods
let's take a look at one of the
separation method in this case we'll
open the igg high resolution
[Music]
within the instrument method editor
three tabs
can be clearly observed the general
detector and also the time program
for this method i will be using the pda
detector
methods are contained within the time
program
here's the analysis of one of the
sample in this case is reduce igg
this is an electro ferrogram of the
completed run
we'll now perform the processing method
to analyze the sample
click process and
integrate
we also would like to quantitate
this method has been pre-configured
users
can use this as a base template and also
modify it according to
uh studio needs you can also change the
labels
if if you if you so desired
and save all the peak result into a
report
here's an example of the summary report
i'll take a look at the sds molecular
weight
ladder here in a minute you will click
in this particular sample we're looking
at the size standard
i'm going to open the processing method
sample number two and the standard curve
is now created or has been created
we're performing the analysis for the
sample number two
to perform the quantitations
now the standard code has been created
molecular weight estimate
can also be generated
in summary the software interface
improved data integrity compliance
a single system cds reduces regulatory
risk
and maximizes method transfer this
driver is available or is also
compatible
with both the p800 plus and the csi 8000
plus in standalone mode
when it is not connected to the mass
pack
the driver have enhanced features as
well like expanded capabilities
over previous version it is now
available
as the p800 plus empower system this
is a complete system where we
bundled the ce instrument along
with the necessary components for users
to connect to the empower cds
and for those customers who already have
the p800 plus 32 carat
in-house and would like to convert that
into
the empower p800 plus we do offer
driver upgrade kit as well
so with that i conclude today's
presentations
thank you handy for that informative
presentation
we will now start our live q a portion
of the webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we've already got
some great questions coming in
handy let's start with this one when
creating
instrument method with uv wavelengths
is it only possible when connect i'm
sorry it is only possible
when connected to ce instrument is this
still the case with version 1.3
yeah that's a good question uh in
version 1.3
the instrument the c instrument does not
need to be connected
for you to create instrument method with
the uv wavelength
thank you our next question i am using
version 1.2 do i need hardware upgrades
when
migrating to version 1.3
uh if you are using the current
empower driver version one point through
1.2 in most cases you do not need
to upgrade your hardware
in some cases when you are using the
older
windows xp 32 karat you might need to
upgrade the firmware
but other than that you do not need to
make any changes to the hardware
tandy how many pa 800s can you connect
to lace
right now the instrument is configured
you can connect up to two p800 classes
into a single lace but we highly
recommend to connect only one v800 plus
to a single lace there's quite a few
data traffic coming in and out
so for for
consistent result and also for a much
robustness we
we recommend to connect just one base
one to 800 plus
thanks thank you
our next question is the driver
supported
with mpower fr5
uh yes the the driver is compatible with
feature release 5. we have tested we
have fully validated also on feature
release 4.
during evaluations our customers have
used the
um power driver version 1.3 on feature
release 2
and 3 as well so it is compatible for
some of the newer releases we are
planning to fully
test again using the feature release in
the next few weeks
handy does the method conversion tool
take existing 32-carat methods
and transfer them to empower
no it does not the method conversion
tools
only migrate existing method from the
version 1.2 to 1.3
if you are currently running 32 carat we
do have
a step-by-step guide in the user guide
to create a method
or you can utilize our method templates
as a starting material as a starting
point
so that you can get it up and running
quickly
will the same error codes be used in 32
karat be used in version 1.3
and available in the message center
yes so what we have done is in this new
driver version the driver
is capable of looking at the instrument
error message itself and the previous
version
error message is only depicted as
instrument error so there was not much
description
we have now fully expanded so it should
be very similar to that of the 32
characters
tandy for vast glycans do you have the
macros to identify glycans glycan's
gu value currently we do not
so the gu value calculations
will still need to be done manually but
we do have the
fast glycan method on the mpower
uh we will be looking at the gu software
in the future
uh and perhaps we can incorporate or
integrate
uh the data coming off uh from the uh
empower
for the first glycem gu value
calculation
thank you will 32 parrots still be
required for the field technicians
to qualify the instrument or to do
troubleshooting
and that's a good question for the
empower operation qualifications
we will be integrating the mpower the 32
carat
will still be needed our service
engineer will be equipped
with a service tool and they will carry
the 32 carat
on their laptop and this service tool
has been calibrated
other reason is we need we still do need
the 32 character
for calibrating some of the components
in the
in the p800 plus
thank you handy and we do have time for
some more questions but i want to
let our audience know that any questions
we are unable to answer
live today and additionally those that
come in during the on-demand period
they will be addressed via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
okay let's keep going what driver does
the pa 800 plus
what driver is the pa i'm so sorry i'm
having to reword a couple of these
what driver does the pa 800 plus
require for empower fr5
okay let me see if i can understand this
question what driver does the p800
plus require um we you will need several
drivers
so you will need the national instrument
gpib
driver which comes with the
with with the new release of version 1.3
so that established connection to the
2d lace box and then also the version
1.3
and power driver itself that allows to
communicate to the empower
software cds
handy for the velocity calculated area
will
empower calculate the tca to give the
same value
as 32 carats
another good question the in the
velocity calculate
area it should give similar value will
not be
exactly the same but it should be very
similar
to that of the 32
and are you still able to manually
export data from 32 karat if
a communication issue were to occur
uh the 32 carat data was
so we will no longer be using 32 karat
in this new 1.3 so everything will be
controlled
directly from the mpower cds so you will
not need the usa
to carry it anymore
very good have the custom fields been
written
or validated to calculate std curve and
mw
yes we have created the custom fields
for standard curve and also the
estimated molecular weight
for for both molecular weight and also
for the pi
value it is being validated as we speak
currently
and handy this question has come in a
few times will the qualification of the
empower driver be performed
by the psyx engineer
uh yes the empower driver qualification
will be performed by our certified sci-x
engineer
this engineer will will be fully trained
on
executing the empower or q3 and they'll
also be
certified and licensed to perform the
empower
q3 thank you handy for this excellent q
a session
i do want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
again as a reminder those questions we
were unable to answer live today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period they will be addressed via the
email address you provided
at the time of registration i would like
to thank andy uwando for his time today
and i'd also like to thank labrutz and
our sponsor
psyx for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we hope to see you
again soon and have a great day